what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
the spider-man no way home trailer has
finally dropped and it was so much more
than i expected it to be it was super
long for a teaser trailer and it was so
revealing they revealed so much about
this movie and they confirmed the
spider-verse we literally saw green
goblin's pumpkin bombs doc ock himself a
blast from electro and doctor strange
talked about how we know basically
nothing about the multiverse now i'm
going to be breaking this trailer down
for weeks now there's so much we have to
talk about in this trailer but let's
break this down the teaser trailer right
away right now real quick thank you to
everybody for following me on instagram
for following me on twitter and being up
to date with me as this happened it was
quite an experience and if you're new
consider subscribing to the youtube
channel now like i said the biggest
thing that this trailer did is confirm
the spider verse in this film no the
other two spider-man toby maguire and
andrew garfield were not in this but if
you've been following my videos you know
that i've stated that they're not going
to be in the first trailer but i've
heard that they're going to be in the
very last trailer right before the movie
comes out but if you were doubting the
spider-verse being a thing in spider-man
no way home all the doubt should be gone
now as we've seen alfred molina's doc
ock electro and if you paid close enough
attention you saw a green goblin pumpkin
bomb and green goblin has been rumored
and reported to be the main villain of
this movie and it looks like we just got
a pretty big confirmation for that in
this teaser trailer and it looks like
we've actually been reporting on some
pretty accurate details about spider-man
no way home and of course i'll be doing
plenty of spider-man videos this week
but let's dive into the trailer
breakdown so the spider-man no way home
trailer pretty much picks off exactly
where we left off at the end of
spider-man far from home now we start
with a little comedic relief everybody
knows that peter parker is spider-man
now and some newspapers are having some
fun in some articles speculating on what
some powers spider-man might actually
have and one of them said that it's
suggested that peter parker's powers
include the male spider's ability to
hypnotize females obviously this is a
joke and it's his girlfriend reading it
to him but surprisingly the newspaper
that she's reading isn't the daily bugle
now right now it's thedailybugle.net
that's what we've seen so perhaps it's
not an actual physical newspaper at
least in this universe now on the cover
of the newspaper we can actually see it
says spider minions and right above it
it says peter parker and h mj's finger
is blocking the rest but i'm going to go
ahead and say this is peter parker and
happy happy helped him a great deal in
spider-man far from home and since the
newspaper says spider minions i'm going
to assume the h is the beginning of
happy so it looks like happy is in a
little bit of trouble as well which
spider-man alludes to just a little bit
in the trailer where he says it's not
just about him it's about the people
that he loves taking fire for this as
well
now from here they do a little recap of
the ending of far from home and they do
a pretty good job at refreshing your
mind of what exactly happened mysterio
framed peter parker and said that he
killed him and it was actually him that
was doing the attacks and then of course
he revealed spider-man's identity as
peter parker and he did this by sending
a very convincing video to the daily
bugle and the trailer picks up right
where that left off in the middle of all
this chaos we see mj and peter swinging
from a web which is no doubt right after
the spider-man far from home post-credit
scene takes place where spider-man says
what the f as spider-man swings by we
see the daily bugle playing on the
screens in the background and we can see
that they've marked spider-man public
enemy number one in true daily bugle
fashion like they have done over and
over and over again we then cut to peter
being interrogated about the death of
mysterio in which he claims that he
didn't kill him the drones did and which
we know but nobody else does the agent
that's interrogating him says the drones
were yours because remember peter gave
mysterio his glasses so everybody thinks
they're peters and not mysterious but
then we see somebody else this person is
not a cop they're not a detective they
have their jacket off sleeves rolled up
and they slam a bunch of files on the
table in front of peter as he is also
reading some files which leads us to
believe that this is his lawyer of
course he's entitled to a lawyer to try
and prove himself not guilty and this
teaser definitely very intentionally
does not show the lawyer's face and i
believe it is because this person right
here is charlie cox's matt murdock aka
daredevil it's been reported and rumored
for a very very long time that he is
going to be peter parker's lawyer in no
way home now all of the reports state
that he isn't going to suit up as
daredevil he is simply going to be peter
parker's lawyer however that's enough
for me as this would set him up and make
him exist in the marvel cinematic
universe now from here we see a little
bit of what peter is dealing with he is
definitely public enemy number one as he
walks to the courthouse or wherever he
is going we can see everybody behind the
barricades yelling at him they believe
that he did kill mysterio and they hate
him now one person even has a sign of
him that says devil in disguise with
painted horns on it and yes i do know
what you're thinking i am thinking it
too and we know for sure peter parker is
mephisto confirmed yeah let's go down
that route again so obviously it's
pretty rough for peter right now but
zendaya tries to shed a little bit of
light on the situation she says aren't
you a little relieved now you don't have
to hide or lie anymore and while she
says this we actually see her and peter
holding hands as they walk to the
courthouse ned is behind them so his
friends and his girlfriend are right
beside him during this hard time now
these next sequence of events are rather
interesting because we can see mj and
peter on top of a large building now i'm
not sure if they actually get caught
here they might swing away from it
because in the upcoming scene we see
that peter and aunt may are sitting on
the couch and the cops show up we can
see the lights in the background so this
might be when he actually gets caught
and taken to jail we also see peter
walking in school and of course
everybody is video recording him so it's
really hard to tell the sequence of
these events the cops may let him go
until he goes to court to try and prove
that he's innocent if they're going to
go by innocent until proven guilty maybe
put him on parole or something but
either way he ends up back at school and
not in jail but we can see how hard it
is for aunt may and his friends they're
all being interrogated and we can just
see how bad peter's life is right now so
he looks for a solution and this is
where he sees some halloween decorations
of what looks to be like a male witch or
wizard of some sort if this is a
decoration of doctor strange it's very
poorly done but he's got the goatee and
everything so it could be so peter heads
to the new york sanctum to see doctor
strange and it makes sense because he is
the master of the mystic arts and peter
knows him because he ran into him in
infinity war and then of course at the
end of end game and he's in new york
which is very convenient and here we
basically get the one more day storyline
from the spider-man comics which is very
interesting and i'll talk about that in
just a bit
well it's actually really the one moment
in time storyline but the ending of the
one more day storyline so peter shows up
to the sanctum and strange lets him in
in which he says what do i owe the
pleasure and peter actually calls him
sir even though they've been through a
lot and doctor strange is quickly there
to remind him what exactly they've been
through saving the universe and since
they went through that together doctor
strange says we're well past you calling
me sir however doctor strange is still a
doctor and he's much older than peter so
when peter calls him stephen it is
rather weird but we have a good comedic
moment here of doctor strange saying
i'll allow it and side note it's snowing
in the sanctum the context of why it's
snowing in the sanctum is definitely a
mystery but we can see that doctor
strange has a lot of clothes on he has a
hoodie on he has a jacket over that and
we can actually see his cloak is over
everything which makes sense because if
he needs to fly or levitate he couldn't
do that if the coat was under everything
now again it's unclear of why it's
snowing in here but it kind of reminds
me of harry potter one when a spell goes
wrong and the office keeps raining and
the other where ron gets nervous and he
makes it snow so this could be the
product of a spell gone wrong here so
peter goes to strange and he pleads his
case ever since mysterio revealed his
identity his entire life got screwed up
so he went to strange in hopes that he
could change that perhaps make everybody
forget it or make it to where the events
never happened and while he's saying
this we actually get a look at peter's
new black and gold suit and it looks
freaking fantastic if you blink you'll
miss it but if you slow it down or
freeze frame it you can definitely see
his new suit so this scene is definitely
after doctor strange does his spell and
from what we've learned about this suit
is it's actually going to be enchanted
by dr strange's magic and give peter the
ability to use magic with his suit now
we do get one shot of doctor strange
levitating in the air seemingly
concentrating on something and if you
notice this room looks like it's been
destroyed i originally thought that this
could have been perhaps some of the
villains from the other multiverses
coming to the sanctum and perhaps they
had a big battle here but if you take a
look at the scene where doctor strange
actually does the spell we can see that
it is already in ruins but hopefully
we'll find out what actually happened
here in the film because it does seem
like a big fight did happen now during a
close-up of him we actually see that he
has the eye of agamotto still around his
neck but remember the time stone was
destroyed in our main timeline and the
time stone that they got from the past
captain america returned so unless
doctor strange somehow figured out a way
to re-forge the time stone i don't think
it's in there however this is clearly a
multiverse and spider-verse movie so him
getting a different time stone is
definitely a possibility now ultimately
doctor strange does tell peter that yes
there is a spell that he can do to make
everybody forget that peter parker
himself is spider-man however long is
there to quickly remind him that it's a
very dangerous spell and he tells him
not to cast the spell in which strange
seemingly agrees to not cast but it
looks like as soon as wong's gone he
does it anyways given our peter parker a
little wink now from here we have an
extremely cool scene because it's
actually pretty much almost exactly
taken from the comics from the ending of
the one more day and from the one moment
in time storyline from amazing
spider-man number 638 to 641. however it
is slightly different and i'll explain
how as strange starts the spell he says
our world is about to forget that peter
parker is spider-man but peter starts to
freak out because he thinks that mj and
ned and aunt may they should still know
that he's spider-man and they should
still know about all the events that led
up to this current event however doctor
strange simply states that that's not
how the spell works and this is pretty
close to what happened in the comics
however in the comics it wasn't just
doctor strange doing the work it was
actually doctor strange tony stark and
reed richards mr fantastic of the
fantastic four dr strange and reed
richards had done this procedure before
to erase the memory of the century from
the world and they added tony stark into
the mix because extremists would allow
him to better control the process since
it was an extremely risky procedure and
just to add to the danger factor that
wong was speaking about this procedure
is extremely dangerous not only for
peter parker but in the comics it was
extremely dangerous for tony stark reed
richards and doctor strange in fact
right before reed richards warns tony
and he says this is serious business
tony you could suffer severe
complications and possible damage to
your brain we're mixing science and the
arcane here in violent and dangerous
ways we never dreamed of before and we
don't know what extremist is completely
capable of but tony agrees to accept the
risk and doctor strange begins and it
looks like this comic scene is pretty
dang close to what we see in the trailer
strange starts and says i have created a
protective cell that will shield you
from what is about to happen enter it
and remember from this moment on you
will be the sole guardian of mistakes
that never transpired remember and learn
from them when the storm dissipates i
will be incapacitated leave immediately
lest you want me to wonder why you're
here now move quickly it has begun so in
the comics the story is pretty much the
same nobody is going to remember that
peter parker as spider-man not even
doctor strange himself who was casting
the spell however in the comics peter
parker can't imagine a life without mj
so he actually brings her into the
protective field as well and in the
comics in the previous stories we've
learned that anybody that he essentially
reminds his identity to remembers
everything that they'd forgotten so
hopefully that's kind of the case here
in the mcu if he tells his aunt may if
he tells ned if he tells mj hopefully
they remember and considering the fact
that we've had photos of mj ned and
peter parker together hopefully that is
actually after these events transpire
and they actually do remember him
because that would be really sad if they
didn't now in the trailer peter parker
as doctor strange is doing the spell
asks can't some people still know and
doctor strain says that's not how the
spell works peter says mj's going to
forget about everything that we've been
through but doctor strange says
something that i think is going to be
rather important he says stop tampering
with the spell peter continues to plead
his case for aunt may and ned in which
doctor strange yells stop talking then
the spell is complete now i believe that
these words are very important stop
tampering with the spell and doctor
strange telling peter essentially to
shut up i think the spell definitely did
not go as according to plan especially
since juan kind of warned doctor strange
about it being so dangerous it just kind
of seems like it's set up to not really
go according to plan here
now from here is really where the plot
is revealed doctor strange says we
tampered with the stability of
space-time the multiverse is a concept
about which we know frighteningly little
and from here we kind of see some
parallels to the very first doctor
strange where he kind of went through
the multiverse himself so one thing that
is apparent here is that wong was right
the spell was too dangerous doctor
strange did the spell to make everybody
forget that peter parker was spider-man
and now their reality and the multiverse
has been severely affected and that's
what this movie is really going to be
about universes colliding the multiverse
exploding into madness because this film
will lead into doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness now from here we
see a little bit of conflict between
doctor strange and peter we see them on
a train and it kind of looks like
they're fighting each other and it was
rumored that the first teaser trailer
would have a scene where doctor strange
and peter fight on a train the rumor is
that they don't see eye to eye on some
things and the rumor for what those
things apparently are is whether or not
to send all these multiversal villains
back to their own universes in which
they will die strange wants to but peter
doesn't now in this scene i think it's
really just doctor strange showing
exactly how powerful he is and pretty
much showing peter look you don't stand
a chance against me but ultimately they
are going to work together now here are
a few very important scenes we get a
scene where doctor strange says a
problem is you trying to live two
different lives now the trailer would
lead us to believe that this is a
problem for the multiverse however i
think this is a little bit of a
misdirect i think this is pretty much
doctor strange telling peter look you
have to choose do you want to be peter
parker high school kid or do you want to
be spider-man and avenger because the
longer you do it the more dangerous it
becomes meaning spider-man with all the
villains that he's going to have is
always going to put his friends and
family at risk and in the scene we
actually see happy getting stormed by a
swat team obviously due to his
association with peter parker and
they're probably up to something during
the film in which happy is trying to
help him but gets trapped now there is
one very important scene that we see
here that's really really quick doctor
strange knocks peter or peter's soul out
of his body this is exactly what
happened to him in the first doctor
strange when the ancient one did this to
him and this is probably the big
multiversal world shifting scene that we
saw just before this peter experiencing
the multiverse just like doctor strange
did however what's very interesting here
is what's on peter's hand his left hand
there's a green cube-like object on it
now this is very very interesting
because there was a leak that said that
there was going to be an object that was
going to be key to kind of keeping our
universe together keeping the universe
that doctor strange and spider-man exist
in together and this very well could be
that object that was talked about in a
plot leak the plot leak did say it was a
small cubed object and regardless of
whatever it is this object right here is
going to be extremely important now from
here on out is what i would call one of
the most exciting moments in marvel
history in superhero history and cinema
history marvel shows us the spider-verse
the multiverse that now exists in the
mcu colliding into one universe and we
see what seems to be five different
villains that peter parker is going to
have to go up against this is pretty
much going to be the sinister six except
they probably won't call it that but
that's what it is so whoever that last
villain is we're waiting to find out it
could indeed be mysterio if he is still
alive in a blink and you'll miss a
moment we see peter and something open
up behind him we hear a roar he turns
around quickly and something reaches its
arm out this is lizard the roar and the
hand reaching kind of give it away it's
so quick and hard to make out but i
truly do believe that it is lizard then
from here we see lightning and a
sandstorm this is going to be jamie
foxx's electro from the amazing
spider-man universe and sandman we
presume is going to be from the sam
raimi universe and in the scene if you
take a look at spider-man in the trees
he is wearing his black and gold suit
and from here this next scene is just
the top of the top the creme de la creme
the best scene to me is where we see
green goblin's pumpkin bomb and we hear
his menacing laugh in the background
this is going to be willem dafoe's green
goblin from the sam raimi spider-man the
very first spider-man film with toby
maguire he is back and then we hear dr
strange say be careful what you wish for
parker and then we see the tentacles and
out for molina's duck from spider-man 2
appears and i gotta say marvel is
actually getting pretty good at their d
aging cgi and he gives us a classic
hello peter and the last shot is peter
parker suiting up in his nanotech iron
spider suit now it's said that the
villains are going to be taken from
their own universes right before their
deaths so if you're wondering why do all
these villains want to kill our peter
parker if he's different from their
peter parker well they're pretty bitter
since the last thing that they remember
is them dying so this is why they all
want to kill spider-man before
spider-man kills them despite whatever
spider-man that is now of course toby
maguire spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man are going to be showing up in
this movie i know they didn't show them
but i've been saying it for a while my
source told me they're not going to show
them until pretty much the final trailer
but i do believe and have been told they
are showing up they're going to show up
and help peter parker fight these other
villains from their universes and
hopefully we get that in the final
trailer before the movie actually comes
out but this is the official teaser
trailer for spider-man no way home and i
personally think that it was well worth
the wait this actually surpassed my
expectations on what they were going to
show us i think they showed us way more
than a lot of people were expecting i
loved it i cried watching it but please
please please let me know what you
thought about it in the comments down
below and thank you to everybody who
supported me during all the update
videos i did i really was trying to be
as accurate as i could and telling you
when the trailer was supposed to come
out and we got it tonight thank you all
so much if you love marvel consider
subscribing to the channel and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos for live
updates you can follow me on twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof